mijail gorbachov pasará a la historia
por su intento de reformar la unión
soviética cuando este mandatario llegó
al poder en 1985 como secretario general
del partido comunista se encontró una
nación estancada por décadas de
inmovilismo y emprendió una serie de
reformas que cambiarían el destino de su
país para siempre aunque no de la forma
que él esperaba sus pilares de cambio
fueron la perestroika una reforma que
pretendía traer aperturismo económico y
el glasnost que abriría políticamente a
la urss
necesitamos más emprendimiento más
democracia más organización y disciplina
entonces podremos llevar a la
perestroika a toda velocidad y dar un
nuevo impulso al desarrollo del
socialismo socialismo
gorbachov se había mostrado muy crítico
con los errores cometidos por la urss
desde la época de stalin pero no
pretendía acabar con el socialismo sus
reformas simplemente querían terminar
con décadas de corrupción permitir el
libre mercado o no perseguir a otras
corrientes ideológicas pero no
resultaron como se esperaba esta nación
no estaba preparada para la apertura al
mercado tras décadas de economía
planifico lo que llevó al país a una
profunda crisis además la libertad
política trajo la crítica al partido
comunista una tensión que degeneró en
que tanto comunistas ortodoxos como pro
occidentales rechazarán a gorbachov que
sufrió un gran desgaste hasta quedar
totalmente desacreditado algo que lo
llevó a renunciar a la presidencia en
1991 sin la reflexión
en esta situación que sigue el
establecimiento de la comunidad de
estados independientes de schubert dejó
de actuar como presidente de la unión
soviética un apuesto presidente es usar
esta dimisión también supuso el final de
la unión soviética que termino
desintegrada en 15 nuevos estados